اذا مشاهدينا لا زلنا معكم نبث هذه الصور
الحصريه لقناه العربيه هذه الصور تظهر
دخانا متصاعدا في عدد من مناطق جنوب
الخرطوم بعد رصد تحليق لطيران السوداني
اعقبه سماع انفجارات اذا مراسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي كان معنا قبل قليل واكد لنا
ان هذه الهدنه تم خرقها من خلال هذا
التحليق للطائرات وايضا سماع انفجارات
وايضا
تبادل لاطلاق النار ومضادات ارضيه المشهد
الان في هذا اليوم الخامس عشر مع دخول
الاشتباكات يومها
الخامس عشر وايضا اسبوعها الثالث لا زال
على حاله هدى تتم الموافقه عليها من قبل
الطرفين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع لكن لا تلبث ان تخترق من قبل
الطرفين حسب ما نتابع فقد حلقت طائرات
الجيش السوداني وتصدت لها المضادات
الارضيه وسمعت اصوات الانفجارات هذه
الهدنه التي لقيت ترحيبا كبيرا واسعا
ودعوات ايضا بالبناء عليها لانها تمثل
متنفسا للكثيرين ممن يرغبون التزود
بالحجيات الاساسيه لهم في الخرطوم التي
شهدت انقطاعا
للماء والكهرباء وايضا حتى الوصول للدواء
كان مستعصيا الكثيرون غادروا هذه العاصمه
وربما الهدنه كانت متنفس لاجراء الكثيرين
40 الفا
العاصمه الى ولايه اكثر هدوءا وايضا عدد
كبير من الجاليات
الاجنبيه غادرت باتجاه بورتسودان وايضا
المطارات العامله
لاجلائهم من العاصمه بسبب هذه الاشتباكات
التي دخلت اسبوعها الثالث لمتابعه المزيد
من الارامل وال
قصص قليل الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات